kommt es zu einer ersten diplomatischen
annäherung so lautete die vorsichtige
hoffnung doch beim treffen zwischen dem
ukrainischen außenminister clever und
seinem russischen amtskollegen wharf in
der türkei wurden keine fortschritte
erzielt zugleich gehen die angriffe mit
unverminderter härte weiter immer
häufiger geraten und zivilisten unter
beschuss die zerstörung einer
entbindungsklinik in der hafenstadt
mario pohl sorgt weltweit für entsetzen
julia schröter berichtet wieder
kampfflugzeuge raketen gewehrfeuer diese
bilder sollen angriffe auf ski turnier
zeigen der bürgermeister der stadt
berichtet
sie haben hier ein kinderkrankenhaus
bombardiert die zahl der opfer muss noch
ermittelt werden
ähnliches passiert auch gestern in der
umzingelten stadt mariupol im südosten
der ukraine
dort wird eine geburtsklinik getroffen
die zerstörungen immens mindestens drei
menschen sollen getötet worden sein
verletzte schwangere müssen aus den
trümmern getragen werden
das sind schreckliche gräueltaten verübt
werden ein genozid an ukraine so müssen
russland für das was sie unserem land
antun verurteilen
die russische seite weist die vorwürfe
die klinik beschossen zu haben zurück
das gebäude sei früher eine
geburtsklinik gewesen jetzt habe sich
dort militär verschanzt
raus einfach nur raus vor allem aus den
großstädten das wollen so viele trotz
der angst dabei beschossen zu werden
auch heute soll es wieder flucht
korridore geben allein gestern konnten
nach ukrainischen angaben
35.000 menschen evakuiert werden
unser haus ist weg wir waren 14 tage in
einem keller ohne licht ohne wasser und
ohne heizung
sie haben den ersten schritt richtung
sicherheit geschafft kinder und frauen
die über einen korridor aus der stadt
sony fliehen konnten ein moment der ruhe
eine warme mahlzeit das ist viel wert in
diesen zeiten
im türkischen antalya startete am morgen
ein neuer vermittlungsversuch
außenminister davutoglu moderierte beim
bisher hochrangigsten treffen der
ukrainische
der caller kam mit seinem russischen
amtskollegen lawrow auf zusammen nach
dem treffen getrennten pressekonferenzen
die positionen liegen noch weit
auseinander
ja erst mal keine annäherung in sicht
jörg brase in antalya die außenminister
von russland und der ukraine sind nicht
gemeinsam sondern getrennt vor die
presse getreten was genau haben die
beiden gesagt
na ja vor allen dingen der russische
außenminister hat lange gesprochen und
hat dabei aber letztlich eigentlich nur
die bisher bekannten positionen
wiederholt er forderte dass die ukraine
entmilitarisiert werden muss auch
entnazifiziert werden muss auch dieses
wort 4 er warf dem westen vor sich
aggressiv gegenüber russland zu
verhalten auch jetzt die ukraine wieder
aufzurüsten und
wehrte auch vorwürfe ab was den angriff
auf das
krankenhaus betrifft sagte dass die
leute da als geiseln genommen würden
russland habe damit nichts zu tun er
sagte auch dass die eigentliche
operativen gespräche über humanitäre
korridore oder eine waffenruhe eben
nicht hier in der türkei geführt würden
sondern von den unterhändlern in belarus
und auch die präsidenten könnten sich
zwar treffen das würde russland gar
nicht ablehnen aber eben nur wenn es was
zu beschließen gäbe und davon nach dem
heutigen treffen muss man das wohl sagen
ist man immer noch meilenweit entfernt
dabei gab es ja vor dem treffen so etwas
wie einen wagen hoffnungsfunken ist ein
ende des krieges nun in weitere ferne
gerückt
naja es ist zumindest nicht näher
gerückt also der der türkische gastgeber
außenminister schule sagt dann nochmal
es sei immerhin ein erfolg dass man oft
der ebene miteinander gesprochen habe er
meinte es gebe die hoffnung dass es auf
diesem niveau vielleicht auch auf
präsidenten ebene noch einmal treffen
geben könnte aber heute zumindest ist
man sich da überhaupt nicht näher
gekommen und so zeigte sich der
ukrainische außenminister auch sehr
enttäuscht darüber und sagt der lauf
habe gar nicht die autorität
irgendwelche entscheidungen zu treffen
die lage ganz allein bei präsident putin
in moskau also erstmal keine annäherung
straße vielen dank in die kein